السيد المصري من معسكر الشاطي بعمل مناقيش
للناس عشان اعيش اعيش الاطفال اللي عننا
مشردين ومبهدلين الحرب ات عنا كثير كثير
على الشعب كله كل مش لاقي ياكل مش يشرب
مصاري مع الناس الناس تبهدلت وشردت بدون
اواعي اواعي عنا وبس مصاري نشتري اواعي
مصاري ن هذا لو ما اشتغلت وعمل مقيش كان
بموت من الجوع بولع النار بحط نار في
الفرن عشان نخبز احنا هذا بجيبه من
السوافه عشان نولع فيه في الفرن ونخبز
احنا بناخذ وقت لما نجيبه ونقعد اكثر من
اكثر من ثلاث ساعاتنا نجيب فيه احنا لو ما
قدرنا نجيبه مش حنقدر نولع النار مش حنقدر
نخبز عشان شتت الدنيا وكان مبلول ف تغلبنا
واحنا بولع فيه الناس كثير بحب المناقش
بعمل زكي كثير انا بتمنى نروح بسلام ونعمل
مناقش في الدار
[تصفيق]
تبعتنا
ا